c'était un personnage étonnant est tout
à fait exceptionnel un personnage hors
du commun et qui a été un très grand
artiste
chacun le sait est un très grand homme
de coeur il a eu une idée simple belle
efficace et il a su la mettre en oeuvre
et ça ça confine il faut le dire au
génie et il restera dans l'histoire
culture de notre pays
non seulement comme un grand artiste
qu'il était naturellement et que tout le
monde a reconnu et reconnaît mais aussi
comme un homme qui a su être
profondément humain qui a su être en
quelque sorte un modèle d'humanité
les politiciens on a confiance on n'a
pas confiance ça dépend mais en tout cas
on sait quelque chose c'est que il ya
officiellement 600 mille personnes
compass a bouffé en france quoi tous les
jours et les mecs vous dis ça comme un
chiffre et quand on leur demande qu'est
ce qu'ils vont faire pour
pour ça ils disent bas et je sais pas
alors nous on sait en fait voilà
[Musique]
allez savoir
d'ailleurs il a débarqué de l'avion avec
une odeur à ce jour n'est une vertu
c'est une mayonnaise qui a monté d'un
surcoût mais c'était impressionnant
il disait souvent et c'était très vrai
il y a les nouveaux riches moi je suis
un ancien pauvre il est rentré dans ma
vie il en est le plus jamais ressortie
convient pour donné on soit peut-être
plus qu'on donne aussi pour monter leur
propre passant par les restos on essaye
justement d'apporter d'apporter de
l'amour quoi c'est cgt dire une chose
c'est tous des retraités ici ils ont
l'air très jeune donc il reste au sein
concerne
moi j'ai une famille du coeur maintenant
tu as mangé l'été avoir chaleur les amis
en soirée de tous horizons et de tous
poils bonjour oui pardon je suis moines
je pense que d'habitude on fait de la
radio alors on se rend pas compte
tiens des gens qui sont intéressés par
tensorer
une cantine gratuite qu'on pourrait
commencer par faire à paris par exemple
picon et al rai après dans les grandes
villes de france
moi j'étais le patron des programmes et
le direction d'antenne europe 1 à
l'époque ils ont j'étais bien mon bureau
là et j'écoutais régulièrement coluche
parce qu'il y avait quand même toujours
quelques surprises et c'est tout le
charme de l'émission je sentais bien
qu'il avait envie de répondre à une
demande mais généralisée et un
quotidienne on le harcelait sur wii
c'est très bien de parler de bandai delà
qui appelait à lutter contre la faim en
ethiopie mais les gens qui appelaient
étaient des deux bons français qui
disaient tous les jours tous les jours
tous les jours et nous alors il ya plein
de français qui n'arrivent pas à vous
fait écolo je répondais de plus en plus
et j'ai pris dans la gueule
littéralement dans la gueule vers 4h30
l'après midi ben et si on ouvrait un
resto et puis on n'essaiera un jour de
faire de faire une grande cantine
peut-être cet hiver gratos j'ai trouvé
son idée formidable il est venu me dire
j'ai l'idée de faire quelque chose pour
que un restaurant pour que les très
pauvres puissent avoir de quoi manger
mais je sais pas comment faire du duché
à l'antenne a commencé à parler des
restaurants du coeur en expliquant et à
partir de là ça a été un raz-de-marée
[Musique]
je file un requin qui n'ont plus rien
sans idéologie disent tout
rencontrant lettre apparaît toujours du
grand frère
mais juste
à manger
[Musique]
et
jours
[Musique]
les chômeurs qu'on peut en manger par
tiennent à personne et donc il faut
donner à manger à tout le monde
notre idée je peux parler de minutes un
bon notre idée c'est donc de re
distribuer des excédents de production
française de l'agriculture de la viande
et puis des céréales des légumes des
fruits des excédents qui appartiennent à
la société française de la redistribuer
j
et savait très bien que les artistes
sont les meilleurs vecteurs de l'émotion
populaire et que comme il avait beaucoup
d'amis et que lui même il était à la
fois
moi je dirais presque un politique et
puis un artiste
eh bien il a fait y ait à ce que dans
cette association il ya les deux aspects
[Musique]
cette fois c'est donc parti pour
l'instant de repas distribués on n'a pas
fait un art on commence le 21 décembre
pour l'instant ce qu'on a fait c'est
qu'on a en tout et pour tout commander
un million de repas qu'est-ce qui va
gérer tout ça j'en perds des écoles de
commerce de france
on a commencé les jeunes des étudiants
de paris et puis maintenant on est on
est implanté dans un région de france et
si alexandre leserman mon fils qui est à
l'époque c'était l'époque étudiant à
l'école supérieure de commerce de paris
qui vient qui m'a dit j'ai une idée on
va faire travailler tous les étudiants
de l'école ceux des écoles supérieures
de commerce de france et ils vont nous
donner une base et mon développer dans
chaque région de france
les restaurants du coeur on a
décentralisé c'est à dire qu'on a
contacté toutes les autres écoles de
commerce et d'ingénieurs de france afin
de couvrir toutes les régions
sur amiens il y avait une équipe qui est
qui gérait sa est qui et qui rentré en
contact avec tes étudiants demandant ce
qu'ils pouvaient donner un peu de leur
temps pour la gestion des stocks ou pour
d'autres actions jeudi ben moi je veux
donner de mon temps je veux donner un
coup de main et puis je suis partie pour
donner un coup de main pour pour un an
ça fait 20 ans et fait un an et demi
que ce n'était pas normal que dans un
pays de bouffe comme la france on déjà
en manque de nourriture quoi
élu dans le même temps des marchés les
pouvoirs politiques
il a il avait un sens de l'efficacité
qu'on n'imaginait pas ce type était
incroyable et cette affiche qu'on
connaît puisque c'est la première
affiche qui est toujours la même et
cette assiette en forme de coeur c'est
lui qui l'a dessiné la fourchette qui
part aussi un peu en choeur c'est lui
parce que l'année la chanson c'est lui
qui est allé chercher gobain il y avait
24 heures pour lui pour une chanson
[Musique]
alors coluche quand vous regardez tout
cela il ya les grands rassemblements des
maires de france
oui si c'est à eux que vous adressez
rend définitives à travers c'est à dire
que aux maires de france où l'on demande
des locaux et des aides logistiques on
leur demande de nous donner des moyens
la locale des véhicules c'est fatiguant
non par rapport à ce que ces
sympathiques que moi je trouve pas mon
nom c'est quand même des journées de 18
heures ben demande entre info ce soir
c'est quoi je dis je dis aujourd'hui
samedi je pars je suis attendu à 9
heures à bordeaux
et puis toute la journée je vais avec le
maire avec chaban delmas qui nous a
aidés beaucoup au départ je vais sur
toute la région récolter tout ce que lui
là il a préparé
et le fait que coluche et ses amis soit
intervenu comme ils l'ont fait comme ils
le font et déclenché un immense
mouvement de solidarité écologie n'avait
pas besoin de ça pour sa popularité
au contraire il apporte sa popularité à
cette affaire là comme un cadeau comme
une locomotive se fait évidemment et
décisif qu'il faut pas se leurrer non
plus tout quand on parle de générosité
publique
les gens qui donnent de l'argent dans
ces affaires-là sont les juste un peu
moins pauvres que les pauvres les riches
sont riches uniquement parce qu'il donne
pas au bien se rappeler ça hein on ne
peut être riche que si on dépense pas
mais c'est difficile à comprendre que ce
soit le même coluche le soir et qu'on
voit là en ce moment par les danseurs
ont du coeur oui moi face à ces tu veux
c'est un peu c'est aussi mon boulot de
surprendre
d'abord en tout cas ce que je peux dire
c'est que c'est plus facile pour moi de
gagner ma vie que deux
que quémander pour les autres et c'est
très difficile d'obtenir gratuitement
des choses gratuites qui existe c'est
plus difficile que de gagner sa vie
c'est difficile d'être militant du coeur
ou et militant c'est dur oui michel
merci va vite travailler parce qu'il
faut préparer le journal de ce soir à
l'infini et puis europe 1 cet après midi
est vrai qu'il savait très bien servir
des médias puis c'est vrai qu'il était à
cheval sur canal et sur europe 1 et il
n'empêche que le tf 1 avec son émission
de janvier a été le coup de booster
nationale
après vous viendrez tout ça ça y est ah
ouais super peu voilà et ce qui est très
bien dans l'initiative qui nous réunit
ce soir c'est que au delà des techniques
habituelles que nous connaissions déjà
on a fait déjà des actions de solidarité
coluche a su mobiliser autour de lui un
mouvement populaire où les gens se sont
en fait des choses pour non pas se
substituer à l'état mais y participer et
je trouve que c'est très positif c'est
une des raisons pour lesquelles
lorsqu'il était venu me voir au mois de
septembre n'étaient pas très nombreux à
ce moment là on se demandait si ça
marcherait lui il était persuadé que ça
marcherait j'ai pensé que ça valait la
peine de travailler avec lui et je le
regrette vraiment pas seulement ceux que
vous avez bien par les faits c'est très
simple c'est que on a calculé combien il
y avait des gens en france qui avait pas
à manger qui ne recevait pas d'argent et
qu'ils étaient sans travail et on a
compté aussi
sur quoi on pouvait taper pour les faire
bouffer c'est à dire des excédents de
production européenne je présidais la
commission européenne et g a pris
l'initiative de coluche je me suis
demandé ce que je pouvais faire ce
qu'ils étaient au pouvoir de la
commission de faire et donc lorsque mes
collègues et moi nous sommes réunis je
leur ai dit nous avons des excédents des
stocks accumulés de beurre de lait en
poudre et de viande sera une bonne
manière de les utiliser que de faire un
don restaurants du coeur c'est pas en
donnant un jour qu'on est solidaire
c'est c'est en soutenant toutes les
idées qui vont dans le sens qu'un jour
les chômeurs vaudois a bouffé compte
tenu du fait que le plein emploi est une
illusion tout cas pour le moment je vous
remercie messieurs dames bonsoir
apporter des dunes
c'est toujours bon et je dis aussi comme
plein de gens disent matin merci à
michel colucci dit coluche à marier dès
l'abord de s'inviter à cette façon c'est
pas la première donne qui la séparent de
la maire sûrement coluche n'a eu aucun
mal
en une semaine a mobilisé tous ses
copains et à ce moment là tout le monde
voulait de ses copains donc à la suite
de balavoine ça a été un rush jour après
jour dans le hall d'europe 1 pour venir
déposer des chèques
et puis on a commencé à le recevoir de
la même façon par la poste et c'est
d'ailleurs ce à l'engrenage c'est à dire
que l'un d'eux mêmes qu'ils n'avaient
pas prévenu qu'il allait lancer l'idée
du restaurant et qui n'avaient ensuite
il a imposé d'office on a même pris le
temps de discuter restaurants du coeur
c'est quand même une très belle idée et
venu par la suite avec l'afflux jour
après jour de tous les chèques est venue
l'idée qui auraient des restaurants
partout et donc il a commencé là aussi à
mobiliser tous ceux qu'il l'appelait en
proposant de venir travailler
bénévolement restos du coeur et on sait
aujourd'hui les bénévoles c'est capital
pour les restos c'est une mayonnaise qui
a monté d'un seul coup mais c'était
impressionnant c'est à dire qu'on était
sollicité toutes parts on avait à chaque
fois composer ont demandé quelque chose
en avait besoin de quelque chose c'était
immédiat les gens ont senti que là
effectivement il y avait quelque chose
et qu'il fallait la compagnie est à pas
oubliée de des os qu'il faut envoyer les
chèques elle est libellée qu'il a
surtout les kits et surtout écoutés
parce que je crois que autant nous on ne
pouvait être subjugué par à la fois par
le clown par la personne par cette
personne et qui pouvait un peu nous
nous a montré et parce que coluche et
pas n'importe qui d'entre eux n'étaient
un petit à côté il ya aussi un banquier
suisse qui nous a envoyé un chèque mais
je pense qu'il a été lui aussi frappé
par le boulou qui avait été fait en
l'espace de moins puisque c'était fait
jamais dans le oui à mois et demi par
tout ce qu'ils avaient pu être mobilisé
un bénévole à la force humaine et si des
fois comme on voulait deux milliards si
un mec nous envoyait deux milliards ont
fermé ça ça nous ferait rentrer plus tôt
si nous on l'a pas dit mais ces
sous-entendus tient à la voile et
coluche le bo coliche la voilà oui
alosi ou parler à l'appareil du mans
[Musique]
il ya eu un jour très émouvant qui était
le l'ouverture du premier resto du coeur
et je me souviens que coluche est allé
l'ouvrir très très tôt le matin c'était
beaucoup trop tôt pour la presse et les
retourne sur une deuxième ouverture
l'après midi parce que les journalistes
avec au prix il y avait vraiment un
resto du coeur et qui en aurait un peu
dans toute la france alors coluche est
avec nous il est en direct à régir
duvillier bonjour collège son jour alors
comment ça se passe ce matin est ce que
ça marche comme tout marche comme vous
le souhaitiez
oui ça marche très bien mais on a tout
ce qu'ils font là était très bien su
d'abord par la municipalité
et aujourd'hui on en a ouvert 18 en
france 18 oui alors qu'on espérait
encore seulement avant-hier on ouvrir
que 11
[Musique]
je viens depuis quinze jours seulement
mais depuis quinze jours origer mieux
manger mais j'ai plutôt hot
quant à ceux qui ont pensé tout de suite
mais ce bouffon ne sera pas crédible
d'abord je suis désolé mais la logique
voulait que ayant lancé la chose ayant
défendu ensuite alors qu'elle n'existait
pas encore l ayant amené à son terme
la contestation est tombé tout de suite
en revanche il ya une contestation
fondamental c'est à dire que les
journalistes et notamment chez moi à
europe 1 se sont totalement élevé contre
l'idée qu' effectivement coluche puisse
prendre la tête d'un mouvement qu'il
juge est quand même assez politique
cette catégorie jantes sont des chômeurs
qui ont une famille quand toi c'est pas
des clochards qui faisait alors
on m'a fait une distribution plutôt
qu'un repas parce que bon venir bouffer
la scène qui peut
ouais
[Musique]
j'ai énormément de difficulté
actuellement et qui sont qui somme
plancher ça m'a beaucoup aidé aussi
bientôt moi qui épaulent écosse
quoi une fois que les cheveux connu la
pauvreté
il en parlait rarement et y avait une
détermination de faire en sorte que les
jouets mis au chômage et j'ai rien
trouvé de ma mère j'ai à ce qu'une jeune
fille est mort quand il s'est agi des
restaurants du coeur rien n'était trop
beau pour les restaurants du coeur
i il y a vraiment mis toute sa vie
[Musique]
je me souviens qu'elle avait dit arrange
toi pour recueillir un solde non
négligeable alors paul simon bah
pourquoi tu m'as voilà quand j'étais
gamin j'ai crevé de faim est un type qui
m'a aidé c'est l'abbé pierre et je veux
lui faire un chèque important du solde
des restos écoutez il reste environ un
million 3 l algérie le portel abbé
pierre
c'est la rencontre avec lui c'est tout
simple pensez à vous associer parce que
on a eu du rab non mais un peu plus que
prévu
alors vous avez passé des petits chèques
en général mes saisons annoncé cette
affaire la fin vous avez vous avez
entendu sûrement causé un peu et puis
ben ça marche bien et puis surtout ça
relance l'idée quoi que vous aviez lancé
qu'il faut être généreux les uns que les
autres
je ne connaissais pas la personne de
coluche mais parce que je n'y ai pardon
les spectacles j'ai peu de temps je ne
savais rien de ce qui faisait sa
célébrité
je ne savais rien et c'est cadré que
l'on a pu entendre sur quelques disques
ses prestations et je me disais que si
ma grand mère la mère entendue elle
aurait été plus forte devinette quel est
l'endroit où les femmes sont le plus
prisé en afrique
bien sûr il ya beaucoup de ressemblances
des initiatives comme celle là et elles
sont une des sauvegardes de la valeur de
la démocratie la démocratie qui consiste
à fermer l'opinion publique qui dépasse
les particularités des parties et qui
met en demeure les programmes publics
par l'expression de l'opinion publique
met en demeure de prendre les
initiatives qui s'imposent à eux et qui
était une oubliée
[Applaudissements]
à partir du moment où on a décidé de
poursuivre l'aide l'aide alimentaire on
peut la faire que trois mois parce que
déjà ça demande un boulot fou un énorme
financement et on pourrait pas faire ça
toute l'année
en revanche on peut faire d'autres types
dead pour maintenir le contact avec les
bénéficiaires et c'est ce que c'est ce
qu'ont été les relais ou rappelé et 1,89
à la mise en place du rmi c'est francis
bourg qui est arrivé à l'intermédiaire
on va se on va s'occuper des personnes
en grande distribution alimentaire et on
a envisagé ce qu'on pouvait mettre en
place et c'est vrai que le jardin
c'était le plus facile
c'était un outil magnifique parce que
parce qu'on est à l'air parce que et
c'était essayer de redonner confiance
aux personnes qui étaient complètement
isolé leur faire prendre des habitudes
et horaires pour proville jeter ensemble
et puis tu là les accompagner et voir
d'abord ce qu'ils avaient compromis même
personnel santé au logement et ensuite
essayer de les villes les former et puis
pour les en sortir les restos
et qui sait
mais qui sont ils
[Musique]
j'ai commencé à distribuer les univers
86-87 il faisait froid un froid d'enfer
c'était vraiment que la distribution
alimentaire mais très vite on s'est dit
on pourrait faire autre chose et
justement en liant un petit peu à
l'alimentaire ont sediba la première des
choses à faire ça serait de reprendre de
reprendre les charlots et de cultiver
pour les restos mais bon ça c'est
parfait ça s'est pas fait en un jour
mais ça s'est fait quand même très vite
vraiment très vite les jardins ils sont
nés je crois à veilleux après à dreux
ensuite à clermont ferrand pratiquement
en même temps et puis ça a été comme une
traînée de poudre
en cinq ans on avait couvert à peu près
à peu près tout le pays
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le but c'est jardin c'est avec des
personnes en difficulté de cultiver de
recueillir des légumes et les offrir
dans un centre de distribution
alimentaire à des personnes aussi en
difficulté donc c'est vraiment un
challenge est vraiment quelque chose de
formidable pour les jardiniers qui
savent que leur travail va bénéficier à
des personnes qui sont dans les mêmes
conditions que coluche est mort mort
dans un accident de moto pas de grâce il
avait 41 ans
il nous a fait rire ce soir qu'on pleure
m
on a eu une sorte de deux moments où on
a perdu quelqu'un de sa propre famille
des l'impression tous écoulés que tout
ce qui avait été fait ben c'était fini
et je pense que heureusement que
l'entourage
ce qu'on appelle les fondateurs chez
nous l'entourage était présent et s'est
posé la question de savoir s'il fallait
poursuivre ou non
fergie - les quatre lignes se sont
réunis et sané qu'est ce qu'on fait est
ce qu'on continue
est ce que on continue parce que ça
montre une nécessité ou parce que pas
mais moi je supporte pas l équité
mémoire de coluche ou est finalement
tous les cinq
nous avons décidé d'être en guinée est
vrai que j ai vu nous rejoindre et nous
à vous est apparu comme étant celle qui
voulait vrai doublement prendra si des
réseaux il y avait énormément de deux
bénévoles qui se manifestaient en disant
on continue on continue on peut pas
laisser comme ça et donc on est parti un
peu pas la bouche en coeur mais quand
même on est parti parmi ces bénévoles y
en avait
qui voulait particulièrement continuer
c'était les avec à leur tête
jean jacques goldman qui avait été le
premier à être sollicité par coluche
pour écrire la chanson des restos et le
petit miracle permanent des restos c'est
que 20 ans après ça continue l'an
dernier encore les
grâce à leur travail bénévole acharné
ont rapporté pratiquement le quart des
ressources de l'association avec
toujours le même esprit toujours le même
principe mettre leur talent au service
de l'association n'est pas le contraire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
plus que jamais on compte sur vous et on
a eu des aides de la part des pouvoirs
publics on a toujours été aidé et ça je
dois dire que les que les les quelques
bords que ce soit à droite ou gauche on
a semblablement ont reçu une aide à
chaque fois celle qui véritablement à
sauver d'un continuation de cette
initiative c'est utile c'est les buzz de
co lui qui est venu me voir quand j'ai
revu plusieurs fois depuis qu'ils
personnes on est mort et son énergie et
sa capacité d'organisation a réussi à
faire que cette multitude de bonne
volonté ne donne pas la pagaille
continue aussi les alpages participe pas
pour mon genou va faire tu penses de
savoir sa fille
voilà donc ce reportage sur cette
journée qui a été chaleureuse qui a bien
commencé à véronique je crois voilà on
va faire le point les chiffres alors on
commence comme il ya deux restos du
coeur qui fonctionne depuis hier 460
centre ouais avec une distribution 60000
euros par salle ressentir le même
engouement que l'année dernière je crois
à véronique ça doit vous toucher
beaucoup c'est un pari c'est vrai que
voilà la personnalité de michel tel
qu'on se disait bon comment ils vont
continuer pour tout le monde d'ailleurs
vu que ça continue
[Musique]
les premières années il nous avons suivi
l'aide alimentaire améliorer la
distribution et quand francis bourg a
lancé ce c'est un souhait alors mais
chez lui c'était plus qu'un souhait
c'était vraiment il faut y aller les
gars suivez moi j'ai besoin de vous et
moi j'ai suivi francis parce que je
sentais que c'était vrai il ne suffisait
pas de mettre le cataplasme de l'aide
alimentaire ça ne résoudrait rien ça
aide dans un premier temps donc on a
commencé à mettre en place en 91 notre
premier petit jardin puis note premiers
logements d'urgence
et puis on a fait des petits seins c'est
nous ce qu'on voulait c'était vraiment à
travers ses activités de travail pouvoir
donner en puces une formation aux
personnes qu'elles trouvent une
qualification et qu'elle ait des bagages
pour se mettre sur le marché de l'emploi
vers le bas et après que trois
mais pat o'keefe tu penses d'un portable
tapas et 3e du 100 m en pâture dessus
conclu
[Musique]
un livre
ouvrier bonjour deux pays si vous
m'aidez quoi c'est ce que je disais à
chaque fois aujourd'hui au mieux prendre
du temps et bien faire qu'elles évitent
été bon to back réceptive et auprès faut
recommencer si je passe et puis je n'ai
pas bien alors être assuré d'avoir un
travail ça c'est le rêve de chacun mais
je veux dire qu'ils ont une chance
supplémentaire puisque nous travaillons
beaucoup en partenariat avec les
entreprises locales et on les invite à
venir voir et à participer à ce chantier
école
[Musique]
l'idée c'est que c'est de ne pas laisser
des gens dans les dans les interstices
de la société on est dans une société
qui est très réglementée qui est très
urbanisées et puis parfois certains
d'entre nous en dur du mal à trouver
leur place et le marché traditionnel
normal on a du mal à y avoir accès dans
l'idée c'est d'avoir un contrât
intermédiaire contrat d'avenir au
contrat d'accompagnement vers l'emploi
pour toutes les personnes qui sont au
rmi ou lss ou à rien du tout d'ailleurs
ce sont donc des contrats d'une activité
de 20 heures ou de 26 heures payées au
smic dans le système public parapublic
associative collectivités locales pour
donner un coup de main et en même temps
préparer ses ressources humaines parce
que tout ça c'est des gens qui ont du
talent qui envie de faire parfois
l'accès au marché difficile c'est une
main tendue
on n'a pas pris en compte le coût de
l'insertion aider les personnes les
nourrir ça coûte
les aider à ne plus être assisté à mon
avis ça coûte beaucoup moins que de
continuer sans cesse à faire de la
distribution alimentaire
mais les crédits baissent pour pouvoir
va continuer à employer les personnes
qui sont venus chez nous auparavant en
compte 30 la solidarité qui aujourd'hui
doivent passer en contrat d'avenir ou en
contrat d'accompagnement à l'emploi mais
il faut bien il faut encadrer toutes ces
personnes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
que vous voyez là à l'heure actuelle
c'est des dons qui nous sont faits par
des
des usines du secteur et ça va
distribuer en la fin de la semaine qui
va être distribué dans les centres
ici sur arras pour on est en campagne
sont gâtés cette année c'est vrai que
superman c'est très très preneur pour
connaître il ya des moments mais c'est
ça c'est l'avantagé d'avoir une bonne
équipe ça passe bien ça passe bien ahmed
est très bien avec moi et ce n est pas
si simple
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
garage qui permet d'entretenir on a
quand même
dix-sept véhicules et m'a rendu service
je vais pas dire que je sens prend ça
pour une dette non c'est pas une dette
disons que l'on m'a rendu service aux
gens couraient sur dix pensent que oui
bon c'est devenu de ses rentrées comme
un engrenage impression c'est dans le
cerveau sait
comment dire
c'est devenu un besoin de d'aider les
autres
même si quelquefois je mon sale
caractère repasse donné 48 heures aux
deux ans et demi pour la retraite
finir en beauté ci après s'il faut
bénévoles aussi pour endiguer mandales
et les restaurants voilà
[Musique]
oui
1 vous êtes là tous en réinsertion
redémarrer défi professionnel
aujourd'hui on a des invités qui vont
nous permettre une bouffée d'espoir
c'est à dire comment ils s'en sont
sortis
comment se sont sortis de l'alcool moi
j'ai perdu accidentellement un enfant de
16 ans il y aura maintenant 13 ans
j'aurais pu j'aurais pu pour trouver
l'oubli et ben me réfugier moi aussi
dans dans ce dérivatif qu'elle agricole
monsieur réfugiés dans les restos j
étais déjà je savais bon et c'est vrai
que pour moi le meilleur moyen de ne pas
penser à moi c'était de penser le plus
possible aux autres donc moi je n'ai je
ne juge pas les personnes je dis que
notre devoir parce que c'est vraiment
notre devoir c'est de leur montrer qu'il
y a autre chose à faire c'est de leur
redonner confiance et de faire un bout
de chemin avec eux jusqu'à ce qu'il soit
capable qu'ils aient compris qu'ils
soient capables de se prendre en charge
seul hic
il y en a qui arrivent le final c'est
obligatoire mais à petites doses à
écouler
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
aujourd'hui dans les restos il faut
savoir que une personne sur deux qui
vient nous voir et est nouvelle ça veut
dire que d'une année sur l'autre une
personne sur deux n'a plus besoin
d'avoir recours à l'association parce
qu'elle a trouvé des solutions
ça casse les l'idée que certains ne
veulent répondre sur l'assistanat
y'a pas d'assistanat il ya des gens qui
ont du temps et de l'énergie qui met 16
ce temps et cette énergie au service de
ceux qui ont peut-être un petit peu plus
de difficulté à s'en sortir pour essayer
de les amener à s'en sortir
et moi j'ai travaillé dans le salon
c'était durant bon c'était 25 minutes
pour une coupe dame un quart d'heure
pour le copom et nous a fait défaut
durant loin ici en feng bâle prend le
temps qu'il faut la cliente pour lui
parler elle se confie à nos voix à café
ensemble
donc c'est ce côté là j'aime bien dans
les restos amis à vos après les arrivées
sandra qui se montre ici et quand il
sort pour les bois de vincennes et
créent du lien même temps le voir qu'on
est
vous mettez aussi que sur le marché du
travail si vous faites des métiers avec
en rapport avec de la clientèle avec du
monde
il faut quand même avoir commandé un
look qui approchent et les cheveux
raides ne passe pas soigner ni même
maquillé comme je le suis là bas sans sa
dépense pas donc on va y aller mais nous
on dit qu'on a le droit d'être comme
tout le monde
séduisant
[Musique]
elle a mis sur pied des préceptes
incroyablement fort qui font
qu'aujourd'hui encore des idées simples
mais qui font encore la vie des restos
aujourd'hui et voilà on exclusivité pour
la une on regarde si la caméra peu serré
c'est un projet de loi qu'il est en
quelque sorte que le résultat de ce qui
s'est passé il ya eu il ya dix jours
c'est à dire que j'ai fait faire sa part
des fiscalistes par des spécialistes de
manière à ce qu'on n'ait plus besoin de
faire la quête comme on l'a fait là et
que une loi d'impôt favorise ceux qui
voudront évidemment donner une partie de
leurs impôts sans que ça leur coûte très
cher c'est à dire que pour 100 francs
donnés ça coûtera 30 francs en
particulier bon alors une loi proposée
par par coluche et acceptées par tous
ceux qui ont défilé sur les écrans ce
pas forcément dire qu'elle va arriver
sur le bureau du parlement si non ça
veut pas dire ça c'est vrai mais c'est
vrai qu'on n'a pas le pouvoir de de la
faire voter mais on a on a le mérite de
la proposer puis si jamais après ça les
gens qui nous gouvernent ne voulait pas
résoudre le problème des gens qui ont
faim c'est tout con porter la
responsabilité quoi ils ont eu la
gentillesse de s'adresser à moi
parmi les français si je peux un effet
les et désire contribuer à se créer on
comprenne bien ce qu'ils entendent faire
s'il faut poursuivre l'oeuvre de coluche
je serais déjà une réussite donc en 1988
le président mitterrand est réélu
je suis nommé au budget fin juin et le
14 juillet 88 après l'émission de
télévision habituel du président de la
république depuis les jardins de
l'elysée françois mitterrand m'a dit
qu'il venait manger un morceau avec moi
c'est pas 2 heures d'après midi tant que
ce soit passé dans ses appartements
il tient alors comment ça va ou aux
habitués aux fonctionnaires à il me dit
je vous préviens qu'il faut absolument
faire voter la loi coluche et à
l'automne à l'eau
c'est ici oui
[Musique]
lorsque j'étais ministre du budget en
1994 on a doublé la possibilité de
déduire de ses impôts les sommes données
aux restos du coeur je crois que le
plafond était à 600 francs à l'époque
cette année francs on l'a portée à 1000
francs et en 2004 ministre des finances
j'ai relevé également le plafond de
déduction
j'ai toujours pensé qu'il fallait
permettre aux gens de donner davantage
au mouvement associatif au mouvement
caritatif sur la base de la déduction
d'impôt
ce qui est important en restaurants du
coeur c'est que l'ensemble des fonctions
je dirais de de gestion cette
association est exercée par des
bénévoles
toutes les fonctions sont exercées par
des bénévoles parce que il est
extraordinairement important que là
encore l'argent des donateurs puissent
être utilisés à ce qui est le plus utile
et puis aussi important que ce soit les
bénévoles
c'est à dire cette force de 45000
personnes qui kiffent qui fait vivre à
l'association depuis des années et qui
sur le terrain concrètement depuis des
années a fait la force des restos qui
et qui donne l'impulsion et le sens
politique
il suffit de faire le tour des restos
pour voir qui se passe des choses
différentes d'un resto à l'autre en
fonction des bénévoles en fonction du
lieu en fonction des personnes en
difficulté en fonction des moyens qu'ils
peuvent générer
il y à 2000 centres restos en france ses
deux milieux différents mais à chaque
fois on est pas tous les deux ans nous
organisons le carnaval des écoles qui
rassemble deux mille enfants
hélas les stagiaires font costumes forme
géante
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quand on sait qu'il ya une bonne partie
de la population dont les enfants sont
en échec scolaire
le fait de retravailler avec l'école de
rentrer dans l'école d'aller discuter
avec les enseignants pour savoir quel
type de costumes les enfants vont avoir
besoin prendre les mesures et cetera on
arrive à recréer du lien de confiance à
simon les deux jeunes ça fait partie de
la vie sans cela je sais
neyret
je pense que toi tu c'était pas une
histoire de te réinsérer c'était une
histoire tout tu trouvé isolé et que
voilà
mais j'aime bien le contact avec les
gens j'aime bien
il faut faire aussi bien le report que
de faire attention j'ai enregistré mon
discuter avec eux pas laisser voler mais
il faut savoir aussi s'arrêter à un
moment quand ils ont envie d'être celle
ci c'est pas évident mais quand on est
habitué on n'y pense même plus ça se
fait automatiquement
c'est naturel mais c'est bien peut-être
le fait que je me suis retrouvé dans
l'europe corps à eux c'est ça qui fait
je pense que ça ça joue beaucoup
[Musique]
très mélangée tous les âges toutes les
situations il ya un grand mélange de
couches sociales ce qui fait quand même
un peu réfléchir
vous faites concernant si vous payez
pour la première fois raison vous
rentrez je sors ma neuvième vous avez la
chose est tout seul voilà ma chambre
c'est la première
la première nuit je vois passer un noël
à ses impeccables les ouvert onze mois
sur douze
faut qu'on a notre médecin tous les
soirs bon il soigne les petits bobos il
oriente
il faudrait pouvoir faire pour eux c'est
les accompagner sur le long terme on
parce que les héberger 14e nuit c'est
pas une solution
[Musique]
et là tu me reconnais pas ce qu'austin
baisse depuis très longtemps on les
restos du coeur distribue à la fois pour
les parents et pour les enfants
mais dans ce cas là on parle souvent
d'un point b b c'est-à-dire qu'on
distribue de la même manière qu'on
distribue les produits alimentaires
adultes on distribue aussi les produits
alimentaires enfants mais ce n'était pas
suffisant un autre sens on voulait qu'il
y ait un lien plus fort entre les
bénéficiaires et les bénévoles et donc
l'idée a germé donc partout en france de
créer des locaux spécifiques pour
accueillir les bébés et leurs mamans et
leur papa
alors bien sûr on n'est pas non plus des
professionnels on n'a pas les réponses à
toutes les questions et en fait on joue
un rôle de relais dès qu'il y à une
question à laquelle on n'arrive plus à
répondre eh bien on oriente les gens
vers les services sociaux services
médicaux services administratifs
compétents
oui oui c'est quelque chose de
particulier madame enjeux éthiques au
niveau des genoux
c'est deux fois plus de deux fois plus
de coups je fois plus de données de vie
j'ai vu un bon soutien aussi pendant ma
grossesse j'ai deux enfants en bas âge
je les emmène avec moi et puis viennent
ils font du bénévolat avec moi parce que
je les éduque aussi là dedans je conçois
pas que d'élever mes enfants sans qu'ils
aient les notions de respect de l'eau de
générosité et de solidarité
si au moins j'ai réussi à meyrin
apprendre ça je pense que j'aurai réussi
mon rôle de maman
la seule bonne volonté ne suffit pas il
faut vraiment respecter un certain
nombre de règles mais en dehors de ça
quelqu'un qui a du coeur et du bon sens
bienvenue au club
[Musique]
anniversaires aujourd'hui celui des
restos du coeur créés par coluche
c'était il ya juste 20 ans aujourd'hui
belle et triste anniversaire à la fois
puisque les restos n'ont jamais dû
servir autant de repas aux plus démunis
67 millions de repas maintenant il y en
avait dix fois moins qu'en que lui chez
a eu cette idée mais ce qui est rageant
dans ce combat au quotidien contre la
pauvreté c'est qu'il faut sans arrêt et
menez nouvelle but il ya 20 ans coluche
était assurée contre le fait que des
denrées européennes étaient stockés
alors que ça coûtait moins cher de les
donner à aujourd'hui faut encore se
battre pour éviter que les techniciens
de bruxelles et une politique de
boutiquiers et pour les amener à avoir
une vraie vision solidaire en europe et
aussi il y à ce combat très difficile
qu'il faut mener pour éviter de se
trouver exclue des centre-ville et des
quartiers
la tentation est grande par rapport à
certaines municipalités ou collectivités
locales de demander aux plus démunis
d'aller dans les banlieues ou dans des
ghettos quinze jours ne peut qu'exploser
les restes ont vraiment décidé de rester
proche de ces gens parce qu'il sent
restant vraiment proche d'eux qu'on
pourra les aider au quotidien et dans ce
combat vraiment dans cette lutte au
coeur à coeur on a décidé d'inclure que
les assad m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on a été les premiers à ouvrir non look
ou à des personnes de la rue c'était
peut-être un peu égoïste parce que ces
personnes là nous aider à décharger les
camions mais ont leurs frais
d'hébergement mais la nourriture plutôt
que d'être à la rue et puis on s'est dit
que ces personnes étaient passées une
certaine partie de leur vie à nous aider
trois mois quatre mois et on s'est dit à
ce moment-là que ces personnes à la
petit à petit pouvait nous aider inventé
un lieu où il aurait pu vivre non pas
pour guérir quelque chose mais pour au
moins qui souffrent moins avec comme
objectif quand même tu ne vas pas vivre
là toute ta vie d'homme qu'il faut quand
même des projets que c'est un bon projet
et c'est toujours été fait comme pas mal
de galles gens dans la rue en attendant
gua
il est un lieu où il se ressource où il
pose ses valises où ils puissent évacuer
tout tout tout son histoire parce que je
pense étaient des personnes quand on
nous dit est-ce qu'ils s'en sortent
peut-être joris en sorte le joe louis se
sont mis à jour avec leur histoire
pourquoi tu m'as dit le tour et camara
laye et pourquoi tous les portois les
clés parce que moi je veux pas
l'employer ménage tous vers la can you
came à tripoli vous voulez poule à mais
je veux la clé bon voilà c'est pas que
le travail va faire les poules d'eau
croupie terrab la baisse et passe à
travailler aujourd'hui qu'ils ont les
gens surtout il veut il m'arrive je vois
pas moi je vois voir la femme de john
quand tu veux
[Musique]
fois au bureau dur dur jean louis page
et ben ouais tu voyais en actions pas
s'arrêtant l'iran à quoi
casse pas les couilles je bois
d'avaugour s'est tenue à vivre qui est
au départ fait le choix du maraîchage et
des animaux et au fil des années je
dirais une dizaine d'années c'est un
lieu à vivre qui s'est structuré qui
s'est appelée vogue la galère parce que
la galère c'est nous en faire on a en a
une épave échouée sur la plage c'est pas
ça ça peut être ça m'évoque à la galère
c'est à dire est qu'elle peut être
remise à flot c'est pas la tête comme
les six leviers comme moi je sais pas
quoi rêver à l'or alors parce que lui
voue du bet et ben lui s'en fout et
alors c'est bon alors c'est cette fois
que je parle je parle pas de l'autre
qu'est ce que tu as dans ton cas
mulhouse ne sais pas ce que les autres
ils ont dans leur coeur
[Musique]
oh
depuis que je travaille je suis bien je
me sens tellement bien avec les halls et
vous
[Musique]
rien
au début connu vient pour donner à
manger pour les canards tout le temps
quand ils me voient de loin il veut
encore et maintenant la porte comme ils
sont contents parce qu'il s'applique aux
de les manger à boire
les pubs je commençais tués il prêche
pas ça vous venez dans mon propre nom
une petite glace ici ça y est
[Musique]
nous avons entre un stand sur le marché
d'aubagne
comme annoncé
à travers le comptable ces personnes
d'aubagne qui reconnaissent maintenant
ce stand est pas ce que c'est
le lui à vivre les restos du coeur
viennent à l'acheter parce que c'est bon
ce produit deviennent band abl
[Musique]
du travail un petit appartement et si je
peux rejouer à mes enfants voient revoir
mes enfants et moi ça serait bien boules
de pétanque
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça en est
ressorti est ce que c'est quand tu sors
d'ici tu as une femme une villa 4
chienne une voiture une piscine
si c'est ça il y en a très peu qui s'en
sortent si ça me sortir ça veut dire
être goûté les pistes de la vie d'une
façon différente que le jour où tu es
rentré jeudi presque il ya 95% de
personnes qui en sortant sont
différentes du moment où du profil que
les avais quand elles sont rentrées
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
l'an dernier les restaurants du coeur
dans leur totalité c'est à dire
l'association nationale et puis les 113
associations locales et départementales
ça représente 90 millions d'euros dont
90 millions d'euros consacré à 92% à
l'aide d'eau à l'action en aide aux plus
démunis et seulement vu % de frais
généraux ce qu'un fait quasiment le
ratio le plus bas de toutes les
associations comparable parce qu au
resto ce qui compte c'est d'utiliser
l'argent des donateurs pour ce qu'on est
vraiment le plus besoin vraiment notre
travail ou vannes au travail qui suit on
voit le sourire des gens quand ils
rentrent on a tout de suite très content
c'est que ça c'est le grand plaisir du
bénévole de voir les visages souriants
quand ils voient la nourriture quand il
doit y avoir quelque chose en tirant que
sont un peu angoissés et quand il passe
et
les voix sont décontractés parti ait
connu des sables que c'est encore une
semaine ça va aller mal combattre
jean tirand drones à un jeune ouest du
caire c'est une action admirable rendre
hommage à ces dizaines de milliers de
bénévoles volontaires qui apporte le
meilleur d'eux-mêmes pour aider les gens
qui sont dans le besoin dans la misère
la lutte contre la pauvreté est une
exigence morale et je dirais de cohésion
sociale depuis longtemps depuis que les
restos existe tous les gouvernements qui
soit d'un côté ou de l'autre se sont
engagés dans cette lutte pour essayer de
s'attaquer aux racines du mal
ses racines que sont le chômage
l'exclusion les discriminations c'est
dans ce domaine que coluche qui a eu
cette idée simple clair efficace
re laissé une trace indélébile dans
notre société pour notre cohésion
sociale pour l'idée que nous nous
faisons de la morale et de l'exigence de
la solidarité
[Musique]
comment un pays comme le nôtre peut dire
tous les reee est de voir cette frange
misère et qui est pas une population
importante
là c'est vraiment très chaud quand on
parle anniversaire parce que c'est des
chiffres il ya 20 ans mais celle
attendent trop end mais qui meurent de
froid c'est pas faire de la politique et
de dire que c'est inacceptable
aujourd'hui que c'est un scandale et on
espère sincèrement que dans vatan bas de
ne plus être là aussi on est encore là
de ne pas avoir comme l'assurent cette
période de 20 ans multiplié par dix nos
chiffres je crois que quand on a la
chance d'être bénévole aux restos
quand on a la chance de pouvoir aider
surtout qu'on garde bien en mémoire
qu'on reste humble parce qu'on ne sait
pas de quoi demain peut être fait pour
nous
[Musique]